Matthew hey how's it going you're back
again that's right a fifth time yeah
it's been what like a year and a half
the last one thank you I appreciate it I
love the hair thank you very that's the
longest I've ever had it I I feel
fantastic so thank so tell tell me
what's going on in your life you well
actually first off if you don't mind i'
I'd prefer if we' just go back a little
bit and uh kind of get a refresher
course or maybe retell a little bit
that'd be helpful yeah exactly um so
first off my childhood you know my
parents were were great they were loving
and caring and um I had every reason to
succeed there was no reason I should
have ended up a drug addict so I just
wanted to get that out of the way and
say you know like I had I had a great
childhood um and uh you know getting to
that when we did that first interview um
I I was just a fan of the channel you
know I had no expectations I just walked
into that interview and was like yeah I
smoke heroin and what about it you know
I I go to work I you know I date people
you know and it's stuff like that and
totally didn't even you know wasn't even
thinking how bad of a problem I had and
so uh I understood I understand you know
I was able to come off a certain way um
but but in reality you know I was I was
deep in drug addiction in heroin
addiction and so then that second
interview I came back and I was more
like remorseful about you or more honest
about the downsides of addiction
because there was one specific comment
that stuck out to me in that first
interview and that was somebody uh said
you know and I don't know how true it
was or what but they said I'm 18 years
old and I've never tried heroin but I
kind of want to now and that was like oo
that's not where I was going with that
you know that's not why we're doing this
no and so the second interview you know
and I was able to see myself from an
outside perspective you know on this
Grand scale which was insane I you know
neither you you or I you know uh
expected that and so I guess it was the
fact that it was just so average and
regular that it spoke to people that
were kind of doing the same thing L
people related to oh man they're like I
would never go and say that on you know
to the public and so I you know I was a
little selfish the first time like oh
man I'm going to be on this channel this
is cool you know and so the second time
you know I was more honest about things
and then that's what led to me getting
into recovery and um you know somebody
an angel helping me out to get into you
have somebody who's been very very
helpful which was amazing and you know I
talk to her every day she's still in my
life and she still has helped me here
and there umazing we can you know we can
get more into that maybe a little later
but by that third interview I was it was
my first time in recovery it was not the
best place ever the sober living I was
at but I wanted it really bad and then I
came in there and I'm like I'm never
going to get high again this is great
I'm sober which you know was not
realistic I was not working a program I
was yeah I was just uh I was miserable
but I was trying my hardest and then by
the fourth interview I am uh it's funny
because you know I try not to I used to
argue on the comments and stuff and I
try not to even read them too much but I
still I'll still read them uh and there
was one there's there's multiple
comments on the fourth interview that
said oh man this guy is so ungrateful he
needs to learn some humility he blaming
everybody else and I remember in that
moment just being like [__] you guys
what do you know about me you don't know
[__] and just being annoyed and now this
is a year and a half
later they were 100% right I was I was
blaming every person place or thing for
my problems and so yeah I guess that
that leads me to today um I have learned
a lot I've spent uh two years a little
over two years in recovery and um I have
you know it's been a long process I'm a
I'm a I I I think I'm a relatively
intelligent guy but when it comes when
it came to getting sober I was a very
slow learner um which if you think about
it you know 10 years of of opiate
addiction and 20 years drinking or you
know smoking weed at least two years to
recover hey it's not that's not too bad
if I think about a grand scale and
however long I live if two years of my
life was spent learning something very
valuable then I'm perfectly happy with
that um but yeah uh I I have learned a
lot and I um I got to the point this
year where I I was pretty desperate um
for for my recovery the after the last
interview the rest of that year was
pretty erratic I couldn't get more than
a month of time sober and I spent a lot
more time [__] up and using um so
this year year um the start of the year
I I went to a it was a year-long program
a highly structured sober living that
um boy um it it was uh it was crazy it
was a co-ed house crazy rules uh writing
a lot of essays and um I went there
because they are very big on Tik Tok and
YouTube and with this YouTube stuff that
we're doing and having my own channel I
thought maybe that aligned I was also
kind of giving my will up and saying I'm
going to try this and uh it didn't work
out you know um I tried my hardest and
um there was just a lot of drama within
the house and uh it it got to the point
where my last day there I lit up a
cigarette in the kitchen and I said
[__] tell on me I don't care and then
I went upstairs and got into an argument
with a couple of guys started screaming
at them and I got kicked out and so um
yeah I I I stayed sober though even
though I got kicked out I spent 420
alone in a hotel room I got kicked out
in 419 and so 420 I'm alone in a hotel
room and there was I I knew I wanted to
go to a different sober living and there
was part of me that said to myself well
you can smoke weed they're still going
to let you in like they're not going to
say ah this dude you know and so but I
was like no I don't I don't want to do
that and so I stayed sober I went to
another sober living that wasn't that
great um ended up getting my own renting
my own room getting a job and was uh was
living in Ventura and um I but but the
thing is that that year um I had started
working the steps for the first time and
got a sponsor and was uh on step four um
if nobody's if people aren't familiar
with there's 12 steps in alcoholic
annonymous and it's highly suggested
that you follow these steps um which six
years ago when I went to my first AA
meeting I was like these people are
[__] stupid like they're crazy they
don't know what they're talking about
it's a cult all the things and they keep
saying these different sayings you know
um keep coming back it works if you work
it and you know live and let God and all
this stuff and I'm like you know all
these catchphrases it's like a Tony
Robins like you know motivational speech
or something but yeah I'm a cynical
person and it's hard for me to buy into
things so this year I I did start to buy
into it because I was like I need to
change something and so um I got to step
four over over three months which is you
know everybody goes at their own pace
but in retrospect I was I got complacent
I um I just stopped working the steps at
one point and then eventually I stopped
going to meetings um through that three
month uh that I was at that program I
did learn that eating healthy well I
didn't learn I just re started to feel
it because I started eating healthier I
started going to the gym four times a
week and there was a a a guy that ran
the gym that would show me you know what
to do on the different machines which
was originally the the intimidating part
about going to a gym is I was like I
don't know what the [__] to do you know
like and so he showed me and so that
Fitness became a part of my you know
regimen and um yeah just I was doing
good and then I stopped doing all those
things I stopped going to the gym I I
started ordering door dash at 2 a.m.
from Del Taco and stuff I was just like
uh I I was messing up and then I'm like
you know talking to girls you know that
I probably shouldn't you know be messing
around with and thinking about sex and
just uh yeah it was too early in my
recovery and I got complacent stopped
working uh like I should have so
needless to say that led to me being one
day in that room alone and on my day off
work being like I just want to smoke
some weed I'm just going to smoke some
weed I'm smoking weed all day and then
I'm like I could just get a bottle of
wine it's just a bottle of wine you know
and drink a bottle of wine and so that
led to me being uh drunk at an AM PM uh
I don't know what the [__] I was talking
to the cashier about but it somehow it
segued to drugs and he said oh yeah I I
Got Crystal now I've only done crystal
meth maybe three four or five times in
my life um and I Didn't Do It For the
First time until two years ago I
previously told that story on another
interview it was in sober living when I
got covid and a roommate was using meth
so wild um but yeah I decided to buy $20
worth of crystal meth and this it turned
into the most insane thing I've ever
dealt with in my entire life I um did
not sleep for 5 days $20 and there's
apparently people say there's this new
thing that's like super meth or
something this and I think that's what I
got because it was insane um I yeah 5
days no sleep by day three um uh also I
should mention I was working at a hotel
and we were doing human trafficking
training and so this is how the
subconscious works with drugs especially
meth and no sleep by day three I'm like
man what the like I thought I was
hearing like uh some loud music playing
and I was like oh that's slip knot yeah
slip I know that song and then next it
was like Leonard Cohen and I'm like oh
yeah this is a interesting person you
know going from slipnot to Leonard Cohen
if people don't know that it's from
metal to 60s folk um and then it was
wuang Clan and I'm like what the [__] is
going like this first off whoever the
hell is playing this [__] like is has
awesome music taste second off like
these are some of my favorite songs and
then I had uh gone out to smoke a
cigarette uh and my my housemate was out
there and in the distance I heard a girl
scream and I was like did you hear that
and he was like yeah and he just [__]
went on with his life and I was like
well who the [__] was that screaming you
know and I'm trying to hold it down in
front of the guy so I don't seem too
crazy um and yeah uh I from there my
mind went wild and I thought that I had
a neighbor that was a pimp I thought he
was murdering prostitutes all night I
thought he was playing songs that I
didn't know I thought he was [__]
with me like and then I thought he knew
that I knew then I went bounced around
to a few different cities thought he was
following me everywhere so I was in full
meth psychosis it was this scariest
thing ever and so luckily I had the
presence of mind and the knowledge to go
okay something's wrong here I don't
think this is real and I started calling
people from the program and they were
able to talk me down pretty much and be
like and I said okay I need to I need to
go back to sober living so yeah that was
insane that was uh that was really wild
and that scared me um I you know I went
back to sober living and uh I started
working the steps again and uh this time
I was like I'm going to work this stuff
seriously and so I was back on step four
after only a month so as opposed to 3
months and I was uh not getting compac
so I was going to a men step study that
was very serious and I enjoyed that but
I was not doing an outpatient program I
had not gone back to rehab after that
relapse and so I had too much time on my
hands and so I still couldn't get it
together I will say and this is all what
I'm talking about has happened this year
I will say that about 90% of this year
I've been sober so that's amazing like
that's more than I have been in 20 years
and I feel way more clear-headed and I I
I feel like I've learned a lot um I did
end up going back to a a rehab program
and I think um one of the big things was
that I finally in my my head I
surrendered which is an alcoholic
synonymous they say you need to
surrender which I scoffed at before and
I the morning I was supposed to check in
the rehab I threw drugs away for the
first time opiates that I wanted I
thought well I paid for them and I then
I thought what if I smoke this next pill
and I die and I don't get into the rehab
that' be you know so I threw them away
and uh that was nice you know it felt
good um and and yeah so I I I went into
the rehab I did the damn thing I I did
pretty much what anybody would tell me
for the most part you know I'm not
perfect still had my ups and downs and
um I completed the program there and uh
went into an outpatient program a new
sober living and everything's worked out
perfect like everything is great and
that's because now you know I'll I'll do
the AA thing that I used to get annoyed
about you with people so to be a member
of of AA you have to have a desire to
stop drinking or using drugs I've had
that for a while um Step One is you
admitted your powerless over alcohol and
that your M your uh life had become
unmanageable and so that was i i i b
basically felt that I realized that you
know I cannot I I cannot smoke one hit
of weed and be I can't have one drink
and be okay there's no more any type of
substance in my life um my life was
unmanageable as I just explain things to
you that are clearly
unmanageable um so yeah I I I I started
working the steps again and
um uh step step two is came to believe
that a power greater than ourselves
could restore us to sanity that doesn't
have to be God there doesn't have to be
any religion involved you just have to
basically say like you know I I I've
been being insane and so now I there's a
power grader in myself that will help me
get back to being a sane person um and
then step three is um made a decision to
turn our will and our lives over to the
care of God as we understood him and
that is um uh what do you call I'm I'm
on step four again right now um and that
one is like I said came to believe that
a power greater than ourselves or I'm
sorry made a decision to turn our will
and our lives over to the care of God as
we understood him God as you understand
him could be anything any God doesn't
matter there not ay a guy in the sky and
then Jesus you know it's not it can be
whatever um and to turn our will in our
lives so the life run on self-will as an
addict is 99.9% of the time never going
to work you're going to have to like
give it up and so that's what I've
learned to do um I like I said I used to
blame every person place or thing I
wouldn't surrender I'd always have to do
it a little bit my way and most of what
they suggest
and so I'm just at the point now where
I'm like you know I'm just fully
invested in it and things seemed so hard
before like oh a year of of a program or
recovery would be so difficult or this
or that would seem so difficult but now
I'm at the point where I'm like no I
this is easier than ever um I I honestly
don't have thoughts of drinking or using
um there's difficult times that used to
get you know put me in that mindset
because I would just be seething with
anger in my head and blaming people and
and thinking that's a huge thing that I
learned is I don't have to react to
everything there's I think also that's
like a part of our society these days
with the internet and comments and stuff
is everybody has a reaction and
everybody has a voice which I don't
think there's anything wrong with
everybody having a voice I just think
we're we're getting to the point where
we're so used to just throwing
everything out there that we want and
not really thinking about how one it
affects others and two how it affects
ourselves I mean so there's a lot of
times where I'm annoyed as [__] with
somebody and people are never going to
change you can't change somebody else
they can only change when they want to
so to sit there and get angry over that
and then react and escalate a situation
or to react and go oh I'm going to go
get higher drink because they did this
it's only going to hurt myself and so
I'm never I I was never going to
progress with that mindset and so I'm
happy that for once I I do understand
all these things I'm at the point where
I know all the answers or I don't maybe
I don't know all the an but I have a lot
of knowledge and it's it's up to me to
practice these things that's another AA
thing is practicing the principles in
all our Affairs um but yeah I don't I
don't want to be a huge AA Thumper but
that's pretty much things I've learned
and it is highly suggested I I would
suggest anybody struggling um with drug
or alcohol addiction um really try to
get into AA and the steps and get a
sponsor and really try to understand the
things you're reading because there were
times I breeed through that book and I
was like whatever now I'm like wow
there's a lot of stuff in here that if
you really think about it's like very
valuable information very valuable
knowledge but um yeah that's that's that
part of that and I'm I'm in a great
place right now when I was at this last
rehab it was funny we did a a bingo game
one day just for a group like we mix it
up and have some fun and you you went
and they were like oh you got to pick a
bracelet out of this thing and it's
these you know little rubber bracelets
or whatever and I win the first game and
I pick out one that says false seven
times and stand up
eight and that's insane because it was
my eighth time in a program and I was
like oh my God I would never wear one of
these things like maybe maybe I should
for like breast cancer or something you
I'm not makes me sound like a jerk but
um no I just this is does not appeal to
me but because of the message I was like
oh my God you know and then other people
it was like I don't know if it's it's
just one of those things where you know
everything's going to speak to somebody
on some level like tarot cards and stuff
which was a whole another thing I did in
there and got some perfect ones um but
yeah this this really was that was
amazing and I was like wow like this has
to be the last time you know like I'm at
the point now where I'm not going to be
like my third interview and say I'm
never going to get high again because I
feel like that's almost setting myself
up to fail what what advice would you
give to loved ones family members or
people that are just helping you like
your your angel in Colorado um
to to watch you go through your relapses
and your setbacks and like you know it
took a lot of patience oh yeah and or it
takes a lot of patience I'm at this
point I don't have to give them any
advice because we've both um on both
ends with all these people have set
healthy boundaries
and the the the lady in Colorado the the
angel she has always been extremely
understanding even in those moments
where I thought oh my God I'm such a
huge [__] up like this is it like she's
going to be done with me and she's been
like you know she she's just she's
amazing I'm so lucky man you really are
um yeah and she uh she she really is
understanding and sweet and encouraging
which is great I don't think you'd be
where you are today having this talk
without her I wouldn't be where I am
today if it wasn't for coming on this
channel it's like all these different
little decisions or you know paths that
have led me to here that's I don't
regret anything in my life you know like
everything that's happened led me to
this point right now and so I'm exactly
where I'm supposed to be and I think
everybody's exactly where they're
supposed to be which you know that could
be a whole another debate but um no my
and my parents uh you know super like
our relationship is so amazing now you
know there's been some struggles over
the years um but it was around almost a
year ago when they kind of stopped
talking to me you know because they're
like dude like you look you look like
[__] you're [__] your life up we got
to draw healthy boundaries and then I
realized man I am and I and uh then you
know earlier this year when I was still
dealing with recovery they talked you
know talk to me kind of like bringing
stuff up from the past or you know on me
a little bit and I just had to say like
hey you know like I have to do this like
a certain way I need like love and like
respect and just please don't beat me
down trust that's that's one thing with
people people and comments and stuff is
they'll say you know people will say
stuff to me like oh you know this and
that about your personality or not to me
they're just saying it in public I guess
um all these little
criticisms trust me dude if you're
thinking that imagine what's going on
inside my [__] head I'm the one that
has to live with myself every day so if
I annoy you on some small scale oh man
I'm annoying the [__] out of myself all
day every day you know luckily not so
much anymore but um yeah yeah I just
it's definitely about open honest
communication and drawing healthy
boundaries when it comes to that subject
for sure definitely for sure um yeah I
and I guess I I spoke about that the
program I was in for three months in
January I don't want to get super deep
into that um it is a it is a strange
place as I said they're all over Tik Tok
and YouTube
which you know you're all over YouTube
but it's like your your um Direction
it's kind of it's It's like a positive
thing like it's bringing awareness and
and you're talking to these people and
everybody's human we're all you know uh
unique and different and it's it's
educational this place likes to put the
drama uh and you sign a waiver when you
go in so they film everything and so
they love to put the drama out there
it's kind of like a reality show and uh
I just think it's not that you know I'm
not like a man this place needs to be
shut down it's just uh there's a lot of
things that I think are
counterproductive to recovery that are
actually toxic for people to deal with
when they're trying to get sober um but
it is what it is and uh I you know I can
only all I can do is what I can do I can
only control myself and my own actions
so it happened for a reason and I
learned a lot and I want to be a better
person because of it with that being
said being a better person and and
learning to love yourself that's a huge
thing people well tell you you know a
lot of people will tell you throughout
life Learn To Love Yourself you need to
learn to love yourself and me throughout
my life you know like there's been times
where I'm like of course I love myself
you know I'm great and then not
realizing oh man like I'm I'm a prick
like I I used to be the type of person
that would just walk into a room and say
whatever the hell I wanted without
thinking who's here what are they
talking about you know am I talking over
them this or that like I you I'm bald
and I'm Brash and you better believe it
you know like [__] man and so I
definitely think of things way more
before I say them like I don't um I try
not to interrupt people there's a lot of
times where I I'd find myself waiting
for the person to get done with their
sentence and repeating over and over in
my head what I'm going to say and now I
just try to listen and absorb things and
it works out a lot better for me but
loving myself let me get a let me get a
drink here
here so I went to this last rehab and uh
like I said I'm surrendering man I'm
throwing drugs away I'm like this is it
I'm doing this damn thing and uh you
know I get in there and do my first day
and it wasn't uh it was actually only
coming off of one night of using so it
wasn't some huge detox for me or
anything um in the second day there was
a detox house and a residential house
for this facility um they h had just
moved a couple of people to the
residential house so I was the only
person in the detox house on my second
day and so I was like hm this kind of
cool like I get this whole freaking
place to myself you know do what I want
I'm going to sit down and watch some
football it was a Sunday night so I
turned the football game on and not long
after it started here comes a new client
coming in they're walking in a new
client it's some girl man she's got her
hat in front of her face she's got her
dog with her and she looks all pissed
off and you know I'm just like oh great
party's over you know my oneman party is
ruined here comes a person you know and
so I kind of forgot about it and just
watched the game and all of a sudden
here she comes and she walks around and
sits down across to me and she said to
me she said well we might as well be
friends because we're stuck with each
other anyway and that put me a little
bit more at e because I was like that's
[__] hilarious and that's so true you
know and uh not a lot of people would
say that or come up to you and start
talking start talking to you uh you know
there's a lot of awkwardness in rehab
especially when you're coming down from
something I will admit I think she was
still a little buzzed because that was
her first day coming in there but yeah
no we uh I was skeptical as [__] I was
like oh God who's this you know I guess
she's funny and uh yeah we started
talking and I'm I was like hesitant and
kind of like huh okay yeah what about
this oh this and that we're talking
about music movies and stuff and she was
funny she was silly and there were
certain things that she said that like
it just it I don't know it was I it
stood out to me and I was like oh man
okay this is a unique person this is
cool I'm happy that this person's here
and so over the next few days uh as we
both were recovering and getting back to
normal we were both mourning people and
so we were the only two people in the
house and so we'd get up and get coffee
and breakfast and talk and stuff and and
yeah chill it was nice
and I started you know in my head over
those first few days I'm like wow this a
she's actually really cool like I really
like her but I'm in rehab like we're
[__] getting better this is you know
I'm not even going to think about it
just play a cool man just be a normal
guy and then so over the next week
things were even more so that point in
my head I'm going like God damn what the
hell like this is this is weird you know
this is is I don't know what's going on
here but I'm developing feelings now and
uh I remember one of the the key moments
was we had to go to a haunted house for
an outing and we both uh we're we're
super similar this girl and I and uh I'm
sure you can tell where this is going we
went to the H house and we're both like
kind of scared like I just don't you
know I'm not I'm not scared that
something's going to happen to me it's
just the ah the jump scares and the the
overwhelming over over stimulation stuff
that's like and she was way more were
scared and we walked through there
together and uh it was that that night
when it was like God damn I wish I could
just put my arms around her you know but
I'm like we're in rehab like [__]
don't don't do stupid [__] and so yeah
over the next few days after that it's
getting more intense and it's to the
point where I feel like we're being
flirty with each other but I'm like I
don't know I don't maybe she's just nice
and Goofy and I'm you know and so there
there was one day where I was like well
I need to artic articulate this in the
best most professional way possible and
so I like just I do journaling every day
most days and I had wrote her just a
little letter and saying like I hope
we're always in each other's lives like
I'd love to be friends for life like I
don't want to lose you I don't want you
to you know relapse I don't want to
relapse you know things are going to
happen you know but I I always be there
for you no matter what and and you know
just no matter what and so yeah I I gave
her that and you know she she was like
oh that was really nice that was really
sweet but I was still in my head you
know because I was like things just kept
getting too hard to ignore and as I'm
you know been through these programs and
stuff I I believe that there is a higher
power and that there is a God and my dad
always says like oh there's signs
there's signs and then I'm I'm really
getting in my head and I'm like there
were just so many things that she would
say that would strike me in this way
that I was like it was almost like a
combination of all these people I've met
in the world that I've admired and loved
and it was insane um and so yeah I one
day after we'd been there a couple weeks
I sat down next to just her and I I said
hey I need to talk to you about
something like I need to have a serious
talk with you and she was like oh what I
was like I don't think it's any [__]
secret that I'm very into you like and I
really like you a lot and you know she
said she pretty much felt the same way
you know reciprocated that so from there
we uh we knew we only had a few days
left or whatever in the program so we
had to be you know we had to be we're
not you know she's she's around the same
age as me and so and we've been she's
been through enough treatment centers
and so have I I've never once uh met a
girl or even come close to a girl in a
place like this that I had feelings for
um so yeah we knew we had to do the
right thing and you know we weren't
trying to sneak into each other's rooms
or anything although at one point we
were in these two separate rooms that
the room in the middle they connected
through a bathroom and there was a
balcony and I I consci iously thought I
was like I could one I creeping there in
the middle of the night hey like wake
her up yeah right so I didn't do it but
um yeah our last night there we had to
go to an NA meeting together and we
walked in and there were no seats and I
could tell it was really affecting her
you know I was like I'm going to do
whatever I can I'll stick it out I'll
stand here and she's like oh God this
[__] sucks blah blah blah and I was
like well there's benches outside you
know we can go out there and so yeah we
got to spend like an hour alone for the
first time and uh just like kind of hold
hands and and kiss a little bit and it
was really sweet and nice and the way we
the way she looked at me that night it
was just like boy I I knew it was
something um another benefit of this was
going through this process together we
were able to see each other's flaws and
shortcomings pretty quickly because in
early recovery you're you're all over
the place and so she had her bad days
and I had mine and we'd always come back
at the end of the day together and check
on each other and it was like I I could
you know I felt comfortable crying
around her I she she's she's hilarious
man she she gets a little bratty
sometimes you know it's cute like I I uh
at this point I'm in love with her I
love her and I I've told her this and we
uh we spend as much time together as
possible because she is in a separate
outpatient program as I am she was in a
sep sober living than I am which is
perfect because it's like we got to
start being around each other all the
time and then slowly but surely there
was more and more distance and so now at
this point we really value each other's
like company like we're just you know
it's it's it's very special and so yeah
she's she's my girlfriend now I waited
as long as I could to to ask for this
because you know there's there's a lot
of old oldtimers they call them in the
program that will say do not date in
your first year or two years or
something like that and there's other
people that you know that have time and
work the program and are solid people
that are like you know that part like on
a caseby casee basis like if you're in a
good head space you meet somebody the
and one of the key things is I was not
looking for anything there's no way in
hell that I thought my second day in
rehab I would meet like the woman of my
dreams you know uh so and and to back to
the initial Point I've definitely worked
on loving myself this year like really
emotionally spiritually working on all
these things you know um and yeah it
just it came wrong along at the right
time which is you know people say when
once you stop looking and you learn to
love yourself then the right one's going
to come along and I truly believe that
she is the right one or else I wouldn't
be [__] saying this right now on this
thing you know be for the whole world to
see yeah yeah we uh there's like I'm a
big song lyricss and poetry and stuff
guy I'm always sending her little things
and she's sending me things and there's
a Cat Stevens song called hard-headed
woman that says I'm looking for a
hard-headed woman one that'll make me do
my best and it's funny because she's
she's kind of hard-headed and her she
she does things her way you know for the
most part and and I respect her you know
she's she's a strong person and she's uh
she's sweet and she does make me do my
best not that I needed her to I feel
like I was already trying to be my best
but now it's just that extra little bit
of uh you know that little bit of
motivation that it's nice to have in
mind you know but I know still know it
all begins with me and it only matters
what I do even if you know we're both
you know she she's more of an alcoholic
I'm more of an addict it's all the same
even if she went out and drank you know
I can't one go join her I would you know
I can't beat her up over it but um I I'd
also have to create some distance and
draw some healthy boundaries same with
her you know and we we've discussed all
this which is the open honest
communication our our communication is
amazing beautiful you know I've learned
these
things which which brings me to uh
another point is that I realize and I
totally recognize and admit and
understand that I have not been the best
person in relationships in my past um
start off with my parents you know my
parents have put up with me for 38 years
and to have their son be a heroin addict
you know I don't think they ever imagin
that would happen um so obviously you
know or not obviously but well they're
my parents and they've stuck around you
know and they love me I'm their only
child uh which I'm sure some people oh
this guy's an only child go figure I've
heard that before um but but yeah they
uh you know they've they've put up with
a lot and I
you know I I apologize to them I've
apologized to them for everything
they've been through uh as I'm doing my
step work there examples that I I will
uh write down paragraphs and and
describe things that I've done and uh
luckily it was you know never like
robbing or stealing from them or or you
know hitting them or anything but there
there like situations where they were so
frustrated and so angry with me and I
was just so selfish and and I could look
back now and go wow that was so terrible
of me you know I love them so that's you
know that's one thing um romantic
relationships though I you know I have
I've been erratic I've I've been uh drug
drug addict alcoholic and and everything
and uh you know I uh I there there are
things that I I you know feel bad about
that I haven't been the best person and
haven't dealt with things the best way
but I can't change the past um all I can
do is uh be the best person I can be
from here on out and control my actions
and and make sure that I never get back
to that place where I'm not myself and
so I you know the steps are in order for
a reason they say the 12 steps of
alcoholic synonymous the fourth step
which I'm on is your resentments list so
write down about a 100 people that you
resented through your whole life and
essentially you're going to find your
part in every single resentment you're
going to find what that it's pretty much
you it's your fault so as I'm doing
these I I started them before but I've
never completed that and that's what I'm
on now you're uh yeah I I'm thoroughly
uh they say be fearless and thorough and
that's what I'm doing for sure um so
I'll do that and then once you get to
step nine that's making a mens and so
there's a lot of people that I'm going
to need to call email reach out to and
there's going to be a good amount of
people that won't respond and that's
fine it's as long as I'm making the
effort you know and so the steps are in
order for a reason so once I get to step
9 that'll happen but for now um I
understand the wreckage of my past and I
am completely willing and able to make
amend these people and we'll do so when
the time comes um so yeah that's a
that's a that's a big part of it now at
this point with all of this that I've
learned and doing the steps and feeling
very
clear-headed um for once I can see a
path in life a career you know a a happy
life you know i' I'd love to marry this
girl that I'm talking about one day um
you know there's a lot of things the
possibilities are endless if I can just
stay sober you know and work these steps
and get through them and then help other
people and sponsor people and work uh
guide them through the steps you met her
when what's up you met her when uh jeez
let me see about a month and a half ago
yeah I know
it's fine though but no so um uh you're
still a little bit impulsive yeah what I
mean dude I really tried not to trust me
like she she said for the first you know
however many uh days like first week she
thought I didn't like her I said yeah
because I was trying really hard not to
to think about these things and let it
be known but from day one I thought wow
she's really cool you know but it it
happened naturally so I'm not I'm not
upset about anything I just know that
there you know there's other people that
be like oh God this guy you know uh
that's that's one of my you know things
it's part of my personality is i i i
with relationships I have fallen hard
and fast before but luckily this time
I'm doing it completely sober and in a
clear mindset where I've thought
everything through and I'm like huh yeah
I think this uh this will work out but
um in terms of my future goals you know
uh I in this outpatient program um I I
drop down to a to a lower level of care
soon so I don't have to go as often and
I plan on getting my it's called rad te
it's a registered alcohol and drug
technician I believe that's what it
stands for um and so with that then I
can work in outpatient programs I could
work in rehabs once I get you know
certain programs want you to have a
certain amount of sober time other ones
you know it's it it varies regardless
once I complete my outpatient program
that's what I'm going to pursue and then
with that once you put in hours of work
doing the technician job and do some
more schooling you can become a a drug
and alcohol counselor and so then I can
help you know with running groups and
help teach a little bit because at this
point dude this is like my area of
expertise you know like I've like
learned so much and dealt with this and
struggled with it myself and you know at
38 years old it's like uh you know what
else there's other things I could do
like I said the opportun the
possibilities are endless if I stay
sober and do the right thing but um I
want to work in treatment I want to help
other people some of the most amazing
things I've dealt with through this
experience is the random people that
will email me or message me and be like
hey you helped me in this way or this
and that and I'm just like my mind's
blown because I was it was never my
intention it was like I was selfish when
I first came in I was oh I'll get to be
on one of my favorite channels this is
cool you know and then over time it
unfolded and now it's like I'm finally
understanding I'm like oh like if you
know I'm meant to be where I'm meant to
be I'm in the right place so I I
struggled with it for a while I was like
I don't want my whole life to be about
drugs and Recovery that's crazy I want
to move past this [__] and get on with
life and now I'm like this is getting on
with life like I'm going to be you know
fine like this is great and so so yeah
I'd like to do that I mean if if I had
my dream goal unfold I would love to
just own my own residential rehab and
just one um not create some type of
business conglomerate chain or something
where I'm like I got 10 places and you
never see me you know I'm just like this
picture on a
website um I would like to just have one
where I'm I'm active and present and
show it's just it's hard to navigate
treatment that's a big thing is there's
there's a lot of shadiness that goes on
in in treatment there's um you know
there was one guy I can't remember what
his name was he was a I guess he was
like an NYU student or something that
got wrapped up in rehabs out here they
said something about him like they
wanted him to kill somebody in the
desert somebody brought that up recently
um that was an interesting video oh yeah
yeah and they they knew who this guy was
and they knew who he was talking about
and all this [__] and I was just like
yeah I asked him like are you sure you
want to say this on camera right on a
YouTube channel that's got millions of
subscribers and he he goes yeah yeah
absolutely I do no and then people were
saying you know backing up everything he
said and luckily I haven't had to deal
with anything that shady um I don't want
to you know um but I just understand
it's a it's a but it's just like
anything else man you know it's like
people that say oh I hate cops and it's
like yeah well there's some corrupt ones
and they make it look bad for the rest
of the guys but there's some really good
ones you know it's you know it's all
different things like even you know like
doctors there's doctors that kill people
you know like doctor death you know was
that was that uh well no no no no my bad
he was doing it like uh he was helping
people uh get out like but they on their
will they wanted to I'm talking not Dr
Death I'm talking about the there's like
doctors that were just like poisoning
people and killing them off like for fun
or whatever anyway who
cares but no in the in the rehab
industry there's also amazing people and
that's the place that I went to this
last time um is it okay if I say their
name I I'm not like on here trying to
promote you know but they it's called
Golden Road recovery and it's in
Chatsworth and it is the first place
that I've been to that everything like
seemed like they really cared like they
want you to succeed and they they care
about everybody it's not just like I
don't know I don't know how to describe
it I just know that it wasn't perfect
nowhere's perfect h of course even you
know in my mind as I said finding things
wrong with every person place or thing
there are multiple things I could have
let derail me but in the grand scheme of
things it's they're so minuscule and
they don't matter and if I overcome
these little things daily you know one
day at a time time then I'm only going
to get stronger and stronger and be a
better person and so yeah the the the
rehab is great the you know like I said
um the the outpatient and sober living
I'm in are amazing as well I'm not going
to tell you the names those because I
don't I don't want anybody harassing me
or something or them maybe once I'm out
maybe on the next interview but um yeah
it's it's uh it's really it's really
cool to be in this uh this mindset and
everything and to just accept Life On
Life's terms and to uh just get through
things even when they're they seem
extremely frustrating because right now
things are very easy and I haven't had
to deal with too much adversity but I do
know that in the future there's going to
be things that hit me out of nowhere
there's going to be you know when it
comes to death and tragedy that's
something you can't control and so it's
how you deal with that you know and and
my parents you know are uh 70 and 65 I
think yeah 70 and 65 and so you know I
understand they're getting older my
father has had heart problems and so uh
that's that's you know it's inevitable
but um all I can do right now is be the
best person I can be stay sober and make
them proud and um you know give them the
best life that I can you know help in
any way you know and maybe one day if
I'm successful then I can help them out
you know financially and stuff but yeah
the opportunities are endless at this
point well Matthew you seem more
grounded than than ever oh yeah since
I've met you yeah and it's all thanks to
you know I'd say to alcoholic annonymous
and the um Step work and just every
everything it actually it's just the my
entire life coming together and me
accepting things acceptance is a huge
thing acceptance is big thing you you've
matured a lot I think thank you I really
appreciate it yeah I'm I'm doing my best
every day and uh I'm loving life life's
beautiful that was one thing I said in
the first interview was um sometimes the
it's the beautiful it's beautiful the or
sometimes it's a [__] up things in
life that are the beautiful things and
and that's true to an extent it's just
without bad there's no good you know uh
so I mean everything balances it out
that's that's another huge part of
recovery is balance you know I I don't
remember the last time I was bored which
is amazing because boredom is a huge
trigger for me you know so if I'm
sitting around the house doing nothing
and then I'm ruminating in it and then
I'm thinking oh drink sounds good like
that I'm already too late I'm already
[__] if I'm starting to think oh man
what am I doing nothing's going on well
what do you think I need to do pretty
much anything but drink or use you know
go on a walk go to the gym make a nice
meal you know call somebody that's a
huge thing I would just sit there in my
head and just be like oh man shit's
[__] up this person sucks I'm bored
there's nothing to do life sucks and
then boom I'm out the door and so now
anytime I'm dealing with anything any
annoyance or like something that's
getting to me or boredom I just call
somebody I got plenty of people to call
you know there's no reason there's no
reason for me to fail at this point I I
need to succeed I should succeed and I
want to succeed and I believe in myself
and I'm very happy about that and do you
feel like you deserve to have that kind
of life where you
succeed everybody does I think everybody
everybody deserves to that's a good
answer because some people deep down
don't really believe they Des like they
don't right and there were times where I
did feel that way you know um I mean in
my addiction you know it beat I beat
myself up because that wasn't me I
wasn't
myself you know there's a there's a
couple of people from this Channel that
I have uh become friends with or
acquaintances or whatever I don't know
at this point um over the over the last
couple years that um I do think they uh
struggle and uh you know it would be
great to see them um come out on top and
uh be um the elves sober and um and
believe that they deserve you know I I
don't know I guess I don't know them
that well that I don't
um uh want to assume things but there's
just a couple of people that I've talked
to and I've watched them kind of fall
off and then I've watched them disappear
and then come back and I understand how
that is because I've done the same thing
when I relapse and stuff I don't your
drug eventually turned into fentanyl
yeah yeah and I didn't really get into
that until I got into recovery into
treatment fentanyl is even a harder drug
to kick than uh than heroin yeah yeah
it's it's crazy it's uh and I mean you
know I think it's it's no it's public
knowledge it's very widespread
information at this point that it's the
one of the craziest things we've dealt
with ever it's the crazy probably the
craziest drug we've ever dealt with it's
killing people off quicker than ever um
there's actually about shortly after we
did our last interview a year and half
ago I went to a rehab um and I was doing
the same thing finding everything wrong
with all these different people and
getting mad but there was one girl um
specifically her her name was Cara and
she was really calm sweet nice every
time she had something to say it was you
know she was she was levelheaded and uh
she was just really she was really nice
and and I there was a lot of people that
I didn't like and so I remember one day
it was after group and I was so
frustrated and she had come up to me and
we were talking I said to her I said you
know you're so like nice and calm like
this I I feel like comfortable like I
can talk to you like thank you you know
and I was I was can I give you a hug you
know like it wasn't I wasn't trying to
and she oh yeah for sure and gave her a
hug and she was like you can talk to me
anytime the next day or the two days
later is when I took off said [__] this
place [__] people morons uh idiots I
don't want to drink or get high but I
get the [__] out of here and well of
course I drove straight to the bar and
then I was on the phone with the dealer
um then a few weeks later about a month
later I was talking to my roommate that
went there he's a great guy I still talk
to him his name's Ryan
um but but yeah I was talking to him and
he said oh uh did you hear about
Cara and yeah man she left there and she
overdosed and up I understand that um
you know there's things happen for
reason there are different things I
can't change people people are going to
do what they want but there's that part
of me that thinks damn she told me I
could talk to her any time and I didn't
and I didn't even you know exchange
numbers or anything before he left you
know who knows if things were different
if I could have helped or been there for
her but it doesn't it really doesn't
matter which sounds a little um cold but
you know I'm here where I am
today because all these different things
happened so I who knows where I'd be if
if things happen differently you know
what I mean so I went to a different
rehab last year in Monteray and that's
where she was from and so I was able to
like we had to do art you know they're
like paint a rock and I'm like paint a
rock you know but I was like no you know
what I got an idea and so I painted Cara
you know in the date and and uh paint it
a little bit and then when we went to
the beach the next time I threw it in
the ocean you know like said a prayer
but um yeah that's it sucks man seeing
uh people die off you know there's a lot
of people in recovery and play people I
know and they're like bro I'm
desensitized to at this point happen so
often I've known so many people have
died and uh I don't think I'll ever get
to that point I I kind of hope I don't
because I I never want to be
desensitized to these things I don't and
I don't want to ever spread myself so
thin that like things just kind of blur
that's what goes back to the wanting to
own one treatment center eventually is
just so I can focus on that and help
people the best I can but um yeah it's
it's getting crazy out there with fentel
and that's what they you they bring up a
lot in these groups and places is
they're always like dude you guys are
doing that fentel [__] it's going to
kill you you know and I there were times
when I was doing it where I was like n
this might be it this might be the last
pill that this might be the last time I
you know and I think in those moments I
was so down and depressed that I thought
I was at peace with it and that I was
fine with it and that if I died oh well
but I'm so grateful that I didn't you
know I uh I I'm very grateful for a lot
of things in in this life I have a very
beautiful full blessed life I have many
opportunities that other people don't
get and I recognize these things and I
uh you know all I can do is like I said
try try my best to succeed and do the
next right thing and uh just continue on
this path that I'm on right now sounds
great Matthew you know it's like having
the gratitude that that you're talking
about and then the uh taking
responsibility for everything I think
those are huge parts
of getting through this yeah my dad my
dad said that the other night I was
talking to him so you just can never
take responsibility as a kid you know
you just always had to blame others and
he said it's a you know it's been a
theme of my life and so it's nice to
finally realize that you know better
late than never so I'm I'm happy about
that beautiful yeah until next time
right on thank you Mark I appreciate it
proud of
you
that